twitter was set up to support 140
characters
and in the english alphabet that's easy
to understand a character is a letter
number space or punctuation mark people
more or less agree with computers there
and if it was 20 years ago that is
exactly how the system would work
that far no further but now we have
unicode
mind you it's still fairly
straightforward in some languages east
asian languages for example
chinese japanese korean one character is
a glyph
a number a space or a punctuation mark
but since the language is
denser each of these characters encodes
more information than an english
character
you can fit almost twice as much
information into each tweet
and then it gets complicated take arabic
for example what counts as an arabic
letter
i mean first of all the shape of arabic
letters changes significantly
depending on where they are in a word
watch what happens as i take the arabic
for
arabic alphabet and start hitting
backspace
arabic is right to left remember the
characters change in order to be
consistent with the rules of the written
language
and the diacritics disappear separately
to the letters they're next to
in vietnamese on the other hand each of
those counts
as one character backspace and away they
go
now it's at this point that most british
programmers myself included
throw up their hands in defeat and just
use existing code by some other generous
soul who's already worked the problem
out
or if they're lazy they just say well no
one's gonna use this who doesn't speak
english so we don't need to worry about
it
unicode has a single character for some
english ligatures like
ffi notice how the letters in official
here are smushed together to make them
look better to the eye
some programs will automatically add
those in for you so you copy and paste
your text from that
straight into twitter and suddenly
you're saving characters
people would count that as three
characters
unicode and therefore twitter and pretty
much every other computer program
just one the greatest example of this i
could find
is the arabic for peace be upon him
unicode
has a single character for this and
twitter will teresa's counting for just
one of your 140 which is handy if you're
a devout muslim and want to talk about
the prophets on twitter
so what counts as a character well it's
complicated
computers see things differently to
people and let's be honest unless you
have a professor who's
setting their essays by character count
instead of word count the only time
it'll really matter for most people is
when they're trying to tweet